et
[Musique]
alors messieurs matin à tournai était
bonne ce matin on est partis de bonne
heure comme d'habitude c'est un coeur
mais ce hacker maigre un peu ce matin
pas comme d'habitude avant qu'elle soit
même bien puisque ça qu'est-ce que vous
avez aujourd'hui une friteuse du minium
une fuite s et de l'aluminium
j'ai un vélo quelques bonnes roues à
l'avant il ya un très bon état ya juste
simplement met une houle comme j'en ai
dans mon grenier je peux le retard et le
méthane est apte pour le band
j'ai une guitare il ya eu des petites
briques que la ferme elle est réparable
vous fait combien de poubelles à peu
près par jour de poubelles une trentaine
et autant de vide ordures chez vous dans
votre maison il ya beaucoup d'objets de
récupération aussi tout chine nuit si
avec trois draps oui j'en ai 34 ou 35
je ne sais même pas combien je les
compte plus mais vous le trouvez sadr
avait poubelle mais oui tout neuf
enveloppés dans des cartons avec le prix
encore dessus et vous vous habillez
aussi avec ce que vous trouvez un habit
et que ça votre tout ça s'en vient
combien de paires de chaussures vous
avez mois une trentaine et de costumes
provient j'en ai au moins 80 des
costumes à votre taille à ma taille
et encore je vous dis j'en en donne à
découvrir et de fermes départ de sud est
et des scieries tout ça parfois je dis à
ma femme comme ça les gens ils sont
embarrassés se disent le matin quel
costume j'aime est le midi lequel
veulent mettre la soirée ils savent pas
lequel m mais moi je fus au même point
que parce qu'il j'en ai tellement que je
ne sais plus de quel métal jaune à
sortir il y a deux ans nous sommes allés
au mariage de ma petite fille à l'anil à
l'abord seine-et-marne avec habillé
mieux que certains du mariage parce
qu'il y en avait qui avait ri pak grand
chose à se mettre moi j'aime bien
manteau à col en fourrure
oui chapeau encore un j'avais juste une
paire de souliers que j'avais achetée
d'occasion 15 cents francs aux marchés
c'est tout il ya des hommes qui peuvent
travailler parce que les femmes gaspille
énormément je vous dirais qu'il ya il ya
plus de six mois où il ya bientôt un nom
qui n'a pas acheté de crème à raser y en
a trop vite tout un carton dès que des
machins de crème à raser il a tout d'un
film même pas ouvert il n'a pas acheté
même pas son rasoir même son rasoir un
rabot là on la trouvait là dedans aussi
pour vous ils pouvaient le ca peu comme
une pochette surprise voilà c'est ça oui
c'est ce qui me pascal justement parce
que je me dis que tout ce que je vais
trouver là et c'est même devenu marotte
parce que parfois je vais avec mon vélo
solex en ville faire une course qui
jouait nouvelle c'est plus fort que moi
aujourd'hui est monté dedans pour
regarder c'est vrai à l'abri même des
fois habité propre palette aux tons
blancs qu'on l'attend
alors le voilà dans la samaritaine ah
oui ici c'est la vraie samaritaine
on trouve de tout c'est presque la quasi
anahi baba tout est rangé par rayons
comme dans un grand magasin lacéré lyon
donc des femmes et bébés et tout est
propre impeccable tout est bien rangé
sur des portemanteaux qu'on a même pas
sage qu'ils la trouvent épartement tous
des toits qu'est ce que pensent les gens
de vous voir faire les poubelles comme
ça au ghana qui nous disent qu'on n'a
rien à vous les indices fiche de nous
d'autres qui disent qu'on a beau lui
qu'on éduque losser parce que justement
c'est bien qu'ils compensent à la télé
parce que il se rend pas compte qu'ils
figurent probablement qu'on couche comme
des clochards
ils vont voir quand même qu'on a un
appartement prône à ce qu'il faut vous
moquer un peu de ce que pensent les gens
alors oui ça alors je m'en fiche
totalement
tout ce qui est dans votre maison ça
sort aussi des poubelles grande partie à
part le frigo et l'armoire autrement
tout en surf et vous êtes heureux comme
ça on n'a pas à se plaindre puisque ça
nous amuse
ça nous rapporte un peu et ma foi on
arrange pas mal de gens non là qui me
disent que je ne suis pas riche
quelle merde j'en ai autant que je vaux
je suis plus riches que les riches et je
m'en fiche pas mal avec et qu'est ce que
c'est
école la fortune 7,1 milliards ou une
étude les gens rient pas seulement des
mois un stage immer vagabonde
on peut bien se moquer de moi alors moi
je me moque un de tout le monde
[Musique]